so what exactly is the angle bis sector
theorem and the converse of the angle
bis sector theorem that's what we're
going to talk about in this video and
we're going to go through a couple
examples of how to use those two
theorems so first of all the angle bis
sector theorem so say you have this
angle here and you draw array that bcts
meaning it cuts the angle in
half if you pick a point anywhere along
this angle bis sector let's just say
right here and you measure the
perpendicular distance now it's
important that you always measure the
perpendicular distance or the right
angle distance because that's the
shortest distance from a point to a line
and what happens is when you draw that
perpendicular distance these two
distances are going to be congruent to
one another now you might be saying
Mario why are these two distances the
same why does that work well notice that
they share this side in between the two
triangles by the reflexive property and
you can see that these are both right
triangles and by the angle angle side
angle angle side the two triangles are
con congruent so therefore by cpctc the
corresponding parts of congruent
triangles will be
congruent so that's why it works it's
based on congruent triangles now when
you look at the converse of the angle
bis sector theorem what is that saying
well say you have an angle and you pick
a point on the interior of this angle
and you measure the perpendicular
distance to both sides of the angle if
those distances are the same what do you
know about this point well it must lie
on
the angle bis sector now you can prove
this to yourself by using congruent
triangles again we notice that this is
uh congruent because it's shared between
the two triangles by the reflexive
property they're both right triangles
the hypotenuse is congruent in both
triangles and one of the legs is both
congruent uh in both the triangles so
that's the hypotenuse leg theorem and by
cpctc the corresponding parts of
congruent triangles we can prove or
showed that these angles are congruent
meaning that this point lies on the
angle bis sector
okay so let's go through a couple
examples so you can see how this works
so for number one notice we have they're
giving us that this is an angle bisector
right because these angles are congruent
so if we have a point here on the angle
bis sector what do we know about the
distances to the sides of the angle they
must be congruent so that tells us that
X is equal to 8 pretty simple right now
if you forget just use your congruent
triangles you can see that this is
congruent by reflexive the two triangles
are congruent by angle angle side and by
CP C see the corresponding parts are
congruent right for number two now a
little bit different here they show us
that the perpendicular distance from
this point to the side and this point to
the side of the angle they're uh
congruent okay they're equal and see
they're at right angles so what does
that tell me about this point right here
it lies on the angle bis sector so this
is the converse of the angle bis sector
theorem which allows us to prove that
these two angles are congruent to each
other and we can set them equal and
solve for x now if you forget it's good
to kind of know the underpinings of this
which is to say that hm this side is
congruent to Itself by reflexive these
are right triangles so the hypotenuse is
the same and one of the legs is the same
in both triangles so by the
cpctc the corresponding parts of
congruent triangles these angles will be
congruent so let's go ahead and solve
this little algebra
equation and find out what x is so angle
bis sector theorem and the converse of
the angle bis sector theorem
so let's see we're getting 2x is equal
to 15 and if I divide both sides by two
x is coming out to
7.5 so great job if you're able to
follow the angle bis sector theorem and
its Converse if you want to go deeper
with me you like the way that I explain
things and you want to learn more about
geometry I'm going to put a playlist of
11 videos that take you through a
typical geometry course going through
the theorems like we talked about in
this video but example problem and some
opportunities for you to practice as
well so follow me over to my geometry
course free here on YouTube and we'll go
through those 11 videos I'll see you
over there